most people just to kick you up when
they talk about greenhouse gas
reductions they talk about you know
pumping less of the stuff into the
atmosphere you say we can capture some
of those gases and store them where they
do no harm now this idea of clean coal
is a game-changer would be a
game-changer for sure but is it a bit of
a dangerous illusion in other words how
green can black really be okay thank you
yeah so what I'm gonna try and do is try
and show you some of the things which we
might be able to do to live with our
present addiction to the fossil fuel so
as has been said we all use all
industrialized economies use about 80
percent of more fossil fuels coal gas
and oil to power the lifestyle we all
enjoy to make the electricity the
transport grow a lot of the food we have
get around training shoes CDs all that
equipment when Edinburgh Castle was
built here people didn't have any of
that they still managed to live they
still managed to have big buildings and
it just shows what a radical change
we've had in about two hundred and fifty
three hundred years and in Scotland were
very conscious that the a lot of the
Industrial Revolution started there with
the use of coal we invented a lot of
that Industrial Revolution and what's
happening now is people in Scotland and
in the UK of course are trying to find
ways of ameliorating some of those
effects what I'm going to try and point
out here is why we need to do this how
we're going to do it where and when in
less than ten minutes now and we've
heard that we're going to increase our
energy consumption inexorably not not
just Western economies but
industrialized nations and I want to
point out how significant that is and
I'll come back to this again near the
end here's the history of the world in
one picture okay so four thousand five
hundred million years ago the earth was
created for the first two thousand nine
hundred or three thousand four thousand
we know very little about it after about
six hundred million years ago
fossiliferous life started then you find
fossils you might know and love like
trilobite like ammonites
like dinosaurs through here chalk south
cliffs of Dover all that sort of thing
you get up to very close to the end and
then we appear tiny sliver less than the
thickness of that red line and that's
now called the Anthropocene by many
people because at this time people
humans have a much bigger influence on
the planet than a lot of the planetary
processes we control now a lot of what's
going into the atmosphere into the ocean
into the rivers and the entire land
having followed the rise of farming
that's difficult because we know about
climate change I missed out the slide of
temperature warming because we've just
experienced unseasonable temperature
warming the past few days we all know
that happens on average the world's
getting hotter much more difficult thing
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
dissolves in the upper part of the ocean
primary school chemistry you can see
offshore of Italy what's going to happen
as that carbon dioxide dissolves in the
ocean that's what the ocean looks like
today nice diverse ecosystem in the
ocean a kilometer away offshore of Italy
same district here and natural carbon
dioxide Springs elevating the acidity of
that water ocean death okay that's
happened SiC five times already in the
history of the world through
fossiliferous life that fossiliferous
life has had 20% 30% sometimes 70 %
extinction and I'll show you slide again
at the end showing we are headed for one
of those extinctions right now we're
doing everything correctly to be a right
on an extinction pathway we also know
that we're in an unprecedented time
because we can reconstruct the acidity
of the ocean water for twenty
twenty-five million years here's the pH
which is a measure of acidity acids down
Alka lines up the point is that's pretty
constant for 25 million years
industrialization use of coal gas and
oil we've got a measurable decrease of
pH a measurable acidity change of 30
percent already okay in your lifetimes
that will change another 70 percent okay
we don't know what the consequences of
that are in detail what we can go to is
the geological record and we know that
the top species on the earth at those
extinction times become extinct
so the problem is this power stations
large centralized power stations large
centralized industrial facilities these
both happen to be in the UK the solution
could be this how can we find a way of
continuing to burn that fossil fuel
whilst capturing the emissions whilst
not letting them out into the atmosphere
is there a smart way of doing that here
it is on a page here is mining the fuel
whether it's coal mines whether it's
extracting oil and gas out from below
the ground taking that fuel to the power
plant where it's burnt combusted at the
moment we dump that in our neighbors
baskets into the atmosphere it's like
throwing your rubbish into next doors
wheelie bin we can get away with that
because nobody cares too much except
that we now know that the acidity oceans
going up we now know that the planet is
warming what we can do is build the
capture equipment we can pipeline that
co2 for 10 kilometers for 500 kilometres
for a thousand kilometres and inject
that deep below ground into salt water
filled bodies of rock which have no use
other than that that's been going on
since 1996 here offshore of Norway
midway between Scotland and Norway
extract oil out of the ground with 15%
carbon dioxide in it extract the carbon
dioxide inject the carbon dioxide back
into the ground
that's been going on about it does
anybody know about that put your hand up
if you know about that what a
well-informed audience but the rest of
the people don't know about it because
it works extremely well if it was a
disaster you would know all about it
okay so this has been injecting a
million tons a year every year since
1996 it works or what we need is a
thousand more of those okay if you can
do that take the carbon dioxide out of
the fuel you can do other things as well
inject the carbon dioxide underground
we've already got too much carbon
dioxide in the air for sustainable ice
caps we have to reduce the present-day
carbon dioxide there are propositions to
scrub the air put air through large
aircraft hangars carrefour scale it's
American
take the carbon dioxide out of the air
but you have to put that carbon dioxide
somewhere when it goes off the screen
underground safest place lots of natural
examples carbon dioxide underground
proposition build artificial trees to do
that they're Americans why not why not
use real trees so real trees take carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere we can
burn coal or gas and gasify that biomass
10% of that biomass co combusted fired
together burn together in a power
station capture the carbon dioxide all
of that we have a slope umph from the
atmosphere back into the ground we need
things like that to get us back to a
sustainable level of carbon dioxide at
the moment that costs money how much
should we prepare to pay that's what the
debates all around are you prepared to
pay the price of a night out in London
to decarbonize your energy system that's
all it is it's about 60 100 pounds a
year per household to do that
my numbers Adam but it's a relatively
cheap price for an industrialized
country to do that yet we're fighting
shy of doing that we need to bite the
bullet and do the right thing for the
right reasons this is actually happening
here's the first one being built in
Canada that will capture a million tons
a year from 2014 here's the next one in
Texas that's going to go ahead and that
will also be 2014 or 2015 is the
European one in the Netherlands capture
here in a new coal-fired power plant
storage offshore and if we don't do this
just to remind you here's geological
time extinction number one this is
abundance of life a potential number one
extinction number through three four
five and here we are we're about if we
do nothing we'll be number six but won't
be anybody around to see it and this is
the proposition in Britain we're now not
leading perhaps but we're going to be
certainly best followers we can do this
at gas plants we can do this at coal
plants we can move even do this by
injecting carbon dioxide to get more oil
out and still be in a carbon negative
position so this has a huge possibility
but it needs to get built thank you
well as a journalist I'm of course part
of an extinct species anyway but I hope
you'll never get to stage six and
Stewart
you mentioned cost 60 to 100 pounds a
year in a country like the UK sounds
pretty much doable but what about China
with all that abundant dirty fuel
available can we do this on a scale
necessary for the world
I don't think Chinese are stupid I think
Chinese very sensible people I've never
personally been to China but people who
go to China tell me that the air quality
in a lot of cities it's not very good
the Chinese are well aware that they
have lots of climate change planetary
change issues in the inland areas with
semi desert areas if we do this sort of
thing to show how it can be designed how
it can operate how the technology can
work then that's a signal to the world
along with those American and North
Canadian projects and then other people
will follow because it everybody knows
this has to be done this question you
have to move forward together nobody's
going to go too far ahead to put
themselves at a disadvantage so I think
yes it can be done let me throw it open
to the floor any questions gentlemen
over here hi it's Doug par for
Greenpeace thanks Stuart for that very
interesting and I suppose I've got two
comments really one is of course that it
it's continuing our fossil fuel
dependence and we can see most obviously
for example in the total rig in the
North Sea at the moment that that has
its own issues both about about climate
and pollution and secondly it seems to
me that this this is like another a
number of things a kind of end of pipe
solution which is dealing with dealing
with waste not well it's trying to store
waste or have waste that is not actually
being eliminated its source and I
suppose I would say cowl satisfactory
Act is it that you are creating wastes
by continuing this process of fossil
fuel dependence what rather than dealing
with it at source so that these wastes
are going to last an awfully long time
obviously they might leak out there
might be continued issues with them so
it's not actually tackling it at sources
it's it's still got waste
that we have to take responsibility for
yeah so I agree with everything you say
really this is not a unique or only
solution this is a like most things
people have done a transient solution
ultimately we you would ideally stop
mining coal you would stop produce you
wouldn't go for tar sands you wouldn't
go for shale gasification but that's the
cheap price dictates that that's what we
all subscribe to if governments have the
courage to put a higher price on carbon
then that will change that's a political
action which needs to happen to
encourage behavior change amongst whole
societies and waste yes the waste is a
problem but this is a relatively untuck
sick waste of course we're surrounded by
carbon dioxide now there's four percent
carbon dioxide in your out breath so
we're going to be up at one and a half
percent in the room by the time we've
finished so we're not going to die of
that and but we need to get rid of it
because it's having an adverse effect on
the planetary system but there are also
other technologies which produce waste
and in some ways one of the blockages
for carbon dioxide storages is the legal
treatment because it's being in some
ways in judiciously targeted it's on
uneven playing field so carbon dioxide
storage in legal terms has to
demonstrate clearly 100% storage for
infinite amounts of time which is
totally over the top and I compare that
let's say with radioactive waste storage
where we have a seventy billion pound
liability for the electricity we've used
in our parents of use even our
grandparents have used and that's an
unsolved liability and yet radioactive
waste can be taken on board owned by the
state so there's no liability to the
producers for storing that waste the
radioactive waste is going to be
subsidized for its storage and the
radioactive waste will be allowed to
leak out in a certain amount within
limits and yet we're putting much more
difficult regulations onto a much more
difficult and serious problem and I
think the politics is all wrong if
you're very quick and very concise we've
got time to trust the two questions and
then of course we need very concise
answers as well gentleman here in the
front and then I'll follow up with the
gentleman over there please identify
yourself like Greg offer from Imperial
College a question about
India and China and other developing
countries where the price of coal is
actually masked by government policy and
they're actually seeing declining
capacity factors of coal-fired power
stations caused by constraints on
domestic production and expensive
imports so if you're trying to introduce
a technology which actually reduces the
amount of electricity you get per ton of
coal why on earth would they do that
let's take a second question dr. Gordon
McMillan from mend I share your interest
in behavior change I work with childhood
obesity but I also recognize there is a
future generation that we have
responsibility for my question is I'm
also a social entrepreneur and that
merits my question so the question is
given that it's an Olympic yeah we did
not be an interesting legacy to suggest
the British population that they might
want to donate a hundred pounds to pilot
your carbon capture and storage system
and invite the government to match fund
that okay so two quite different
questions there and the first one we
talked about China briefly India is a
different country we tend might tend to
lump them together as viewed from our
perspective in Europe I think they're
entirely different countries need
different solutions and the Indians will
not go this route at the moment they
will go this route when they find an
Indian solution for India and that's
absolutely fine that should not stop us
doing a solution which works for us
second type of solution yes I think we
need serious engagement with the public
to get the public to realize what a
major issue energy is and that's what a
lot of people speakers should talk about
tonight it's a fundamental part of our
culture which we're not paying attention
to so anything like you suggest if you
could get that buy-in that would be
terrific if you can organize it in time
then I'll come
well we could spend all night talking
about this particular issue but I'm
afraid we're gonna have to move on thank
you so much